[Musique]
ça fait rêver
j'imagine que celle d'abou dhabi mais
souligné mike me fais l'effet de base
est là tu ailles plus lumière des jeunes
sont obligés de quitter constructive
après le collège parce que j'ai ressenti
il n'y a pas de lycée ne prendre pas mal
quand je vois comment je vais faire des
choses il va le prendre et pendant
prendre d'abord
[Musique]
dan dan en faire et vite
mais rêver tu en as trop note je veux
faire astro boy astronautes
ouais bah ouais les doigts présente
petit discutailler copine tu dis moi je
veux aussi aller en france quoi un petit
peu non ouais ils disent quoi elle tout
le monde parte
voilà là mais il va plus rester personne
en fait partie on va revenir à d'accord
tu vas revenir non c'est bien vous allez
tu as trop longtemps on a franchi ty
segall asama vous attend et aigus
moment-là mais pas que toi j'étais chez
moi travail comme
[Musique]